to Las Vegas parents are suing CCSD over  an assignment where they say their 15  year old daughter was required to read  an expletive lace monologue now you may  remember in May when the student's mom  brought concerns to the Board of  Trustees that mother was reading the  monologue which included several  expletives when her mic went dead  if you don't want me to read it to you  what was that like for my 15 year old  daughter to have to memorize  pornographic material and  um  and memorize it and which  Madam president members of the board  stats on this  the lawsuit claim CCSD and the teacher  were negligent among other allegations  CCSD does not comment on pending  litigation